Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to "Enter the Gungeon"!
Just judging by the music, and the music is fricking AWESOME here,
This game is going to be incredible.
It's actually a top seller, even though it's a new release on Steam.
'The Marine'. I don't- oh! I'm character selecting. Okay.
'The Convict'? Who looks like a.. VERY angry lady.
Cocky pilot... The marine... The hunter with a dog... Oh!
So I got a choice here.
That guy has kinda like the fohawk that I had before and kinda red hair
but she has a dog.... Oh,
I'd love to go around with Chica because I got Chica in the room right now!
She's laying down over there. She's very tired, she's been playing all day.
So I'm gonna go with that one.
Who are you? Enter co-op? I don't have any friends!
I got no-one to play with. I'm literally by myself forever and ever and ever.
Where does this go?! [Totally not the Gungeon!]
Hi- okay. I guess I WON'T go in there.
Have a nice day! I'll go fuck myself. It's great.
Okay, so I see I should have just gone North.
This would've been the obvious choice, but then again I'm incredibly stupid. HI!
[Mark as NPC voice] "Well what do we have here?
You must be a new arrival."
"Lemme guess. Here to change the past, right? Well you're not the first."
"But there's no salvation here."
"I was like you once, came to change the past."
"And now I have no future..."
[Mark as NPC laughing]
Well, maybe it's because you drank it all away.
Alright, here we go!
Now, the only thing I know about this game is that it has to do with guns
and it's kind of a bullet hell... ?
"The Halls of Knowledge", Okay
Hello. HI! Anybody here to kill me?
Anybody here for me to kill- Hello o_o
[Mark as NPC] "WAYWARD SOUL! Approach me and press A to speak!"
"For it is I, Ser Manuel!"
"Heed my words and I shall show you how
to survive this accursed labyrinth."
*snotty inhale*
"Continue through the door to begin the tutelage."
[Mark's normal voice] OKAY!!!! ON MY WAY TEACHER!!!
[Mark as NPC] "Try flipping these tables or kicking barrels with the A button."
[Mark's normal voice] Yeah, fuck that table! Yeah, fuck that barrel!
AND FUCK ALL Y'ALL!!!! HEHEHE!!
[Mark as NPC] "Excellent interacting. Proceed to the next room."
[Mark's normal voice] Wait, I'm not done fucking all the barrels!
AAAAHAHA! Okay. I'm done.
Alright, moving on. You're such a good teacher. What is this? Is this bad?
[Mark as NPC] "This is the most important lesson:
you can dodge roll by pressing L bumper and a direction."
"Invulnerable for the
first half of the dodge..."
[Mark's normal voice] Okay... *understanding aaah*
Okay! Gotcha! Okay.
I can do it! I'm on it! In it to win it!
Do it!
aaaaAAAH BOINK!
heheheh! BOINK! hehehehah!
BOINK! That's awesome!
BOINK! *childish laughter*
Ooh, what? Is this not good enough?
Oh, thank you! *laughs*
[Still giggling] That door was very angry with me.
[Mark's normal voice] I love this game already!
HEEEAH!
*giggling*
This is so cool!
HAAAhahah!
I mean, I know it's very simplistic, and obviously
this is just a game but whatever. It's cool.
Oh, okay, nevermind - I already did it!
I did the challenge because I'm really good at games.
Ah fuck this barrel! Okay...
[Mark as NPC] "Avoid dying... number of bullets can be overwhelming..."
[Mark's normal voice] Oh hello!
[Mark as NPC] "for instan- no dodging through that,
but there's a way to clear a path."
"BLANKS."
"Using one will defeat all enemy projectiles in a room"
"and stop enemies from shooting for a short period."
*Deep inhale*
"They will also push nearby enemies away. Great if you need a second to reposition."
"Pick them up by over-"
[Mark's normal voice] ooOOh. Okay that's handy-dandy.
Okay...
Okay got it. BOINK!!!!!!
WOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!! Alrighty then.
Good for me.
FUCK ALL Y'ALL!
Okay.
[Mark as NPC] "Excellent!"
"Blanks refill every floor, so use them when you need to!"
"They can also be found through out the Gungeon, but I wouldn't rely on that... Onward!!"
[Mark's normal voice] Okay! Thanks boss!!!
Excuse me- HUAH!
Alright, FUCK YOU!!! FUCK YES!
FUCK ALL Y'ALL!!!!
*laughs menacingly* okay
HOOP!
Am I supposed to talk to you?
[Mark as NPC] "You got the basics,
I suppose you've earned a reward:"
"a gun befitting your stature and experience."
[Mark's normal voice] COOL!!!
Sweet! It's a pea shooter! Quite literally.
*laughs* Oh, it IS a pea shooter. Oh, okay.
Alrighty then. Reload... [reading] "First you need something to shoot."
"One of the Gungeon's natural inhabitants... cruel, savage, and bloodthirsty."
AH GOD! It's a... it's a bullet!?
Oh okay.
[as NPC] "Now, that's why it's called a Gungeon."
"Kill him!"
[Mark's normal voice] Well, that's a little...
Wait.
Oh. Right bumper shoots...?
Oh that's gonna be- Oh, that's gonna be hard.
[as NPC] "Cold-blooded, truly ruthless you are!" ((Hides the fact he gave Mark the gun))
[as Mark] Man, you MADE me this way, teacher!
I didn't want to be! I came in around here to be PEACEFUL!
[as NPC] "The next rooms will be real gun fights."
"Kill all the enemies in each room,
and the doors will open."
"I'll meet you in a few rooms ahead."
Okay, bye teacher! Hueeaugh! *more Mark sound effects*
How do I reload? Oh, like that!
*shooting, sounds of joy, laughing*
I'm killing bullets!
*more laughing*
Heaagh! Books! HEEaagh! *giggle*
Sorry, I'm having a little too much fun on this one.
HEOOP!
You wanna dance with me, brah?
You shouldn't! Whoah, hello.
HOOP! hahahahah!
I'm too good for y'all! *laughs*
I don't know why I'm saying "y'all." I'm not even from Kentucky.
I'm from Cincinnati.
u-WOAH! Hello!
That guy means business. HEP! Okay, well, he doesn't mean business no more.
[as NPC] "Over here!"
[as Mark] Hello! I made it!
[as NPC] "You know how to dodge, roll, shoot, and use blanks, but there's more to learn."
"You need to know how to use items that don't exist in gun form. This Medkit, for example."
"It will replenish your health. Pick it up by pshereblahblahblah" *done reading*
Okay. "You've got plenty of health, so don't use it"...
"Right trigger button to use it."
Man, why the right trigger?
Okay, now-
Yeah, that's much, that's much better!
Yeah, much better.
"Go on." Okay boss!
HAHAHAHA!
HELLO!
What is THAT?
"You see that thing? That's a Teleporter."
Thanks for answering my question, buddy.
"To use it, open the map by left trigger-"
[bleep]
Okay. Alright. It's actually left BUMPER now.
Okay...
How do I get over to it? I wasn't paying attention to anything that you were saying!
You are old man!
I'm no- "Whoops."
Oh, shit!
I didn't- [thud] Okay.
What-
Ohhh!
That's right, okay. I shouldn't skip over.
There are literally- ahh, okay.
GOT IT! Okay, I can teleport to the Teleporter any time. *Fumbling over words*
*Inhale*
Okay, they won't work if I'm in combat,
"press 'A' while standing on the portal to teleport back where you were"...
"Should explore... better find the boss".
OKAY! I'LL FIND THE BOSS!
Okay, those were nothing.
I thought those were gonna be something.
Hello?
Hello~?
HELLO!
Okay, sorry, didn't mean to do that.
Hi!
Okay, goodbye!
Anybody here wanna fight? HUH?
Wanna fight with me br- OH! Heyy!
That guy just blew himself up!
Why did he do that?
AH!
Nononono~
This is a really cool bullet hell, I gotta admit because,
it's kinda stylistic in a great way
which I always like out of games. But also this one is just...
BONKERS in terms this, like, the ah, atmosphere of it.
Like the music and like it all works together.
Hep!
Cool, I got- I-
Okay, so tables are defensive structures, which are very handy.
[unsympathetically] Oh no, poor guys.
I got a blank. Good for me, no boss here.
So I just need to scout out the rest of
dungeons until I find a boss
and then I need to kick him in the ass until he gets an idea that I'm the boss now.
Hup!
Not very clever when I say-
Oh, is that the boss? Oh.
[chuckles]
That's metal as fuck, bro.
Hello! What? Are you the boss?
...You're the boss?
"You ready to put all you-" yeah, let's do it.
"Then... face me in si-" Ok.
Fine then! I don't care, I just met you.
"Let's begin!" All right.
Fine, Ser Manuel.
Hup!
There you go! Aw you're going to lose it now.
Nope, nope no no. Why did you give me a pea shooter?
It's almost as if he really wanted me to lose this because
obviously he's a little bit better at this than me,
considering how many guns- how many bullets he can shoot at me-
Sorry, trying to think.
Think and move at the same time.
Quite difficult.
Hup!
I actually might switch to the-
Hey!
'Cease fire'? Never!
*giggles*
Hello! Boink.
Can I- No? Okay.
"You've bested me... I, the great Manuel!"
"So long have I ruled these halls, only to be undone by the likes of you."
"The reign of Ser Manuel, master of the Gungeon ends unceremoniously"
[giggling] "You've done it, you beat the entire game."
"Leave me here to die, again!"
Okay...
[laughing at the expense of Ser Manuel's misery]
Alright, move!
I did it! I'm the best!
Oh, hello.
Well, that was weird.
Things seem to be quite bullet-themed and I love it.
Oh man, this is so cool.
Oh, it just said 'generating'. It must be randomly generated for the most of it.
Hello! Did my poochie help me at all?
'Enter Co-Op?' No, I don't even know what that is.
Can I- Can I try
mouse and keyboard? Because I have a funny feeling that it's gonna be a little bit easier.
Hello!
"Oh, have you seen that misguided spirit, Ser Manuel?"
"He's stuck in those halls, lost. Sad, really."
Okay, good for him! At least he taught me what I was supposed to be doing,
other than you, teaching me that alcoholism is bad.
Hup!
Hello!
Oh, hi again!
Wait. Oh, it's you.
"Forget how to dodge roll?" No, I'm good.
"Take the stairs back up to the breach!"
No, wha- Whathe-
Why won't you let me through? Did they let me through?
I may-I might've just had a seizure and thought they blocked me off from the entrance
which would've been much, much much much much much more...
Interesting.
Hello!
Now excuse me, can I- please?
"You are now ready to Enter... the Gungeon."
Oh.
Well, thank you, I didn't know that I-
I didn't know that I needed to TALK my way through things.
I've only been taught to kill.
Literally, I'm completely bloodthirsty against anything that looks like a bullet, so...
I'm going to destroy everyone that I come across.
... Except my little poochie-woochie!
Uh-oh.
That doesn't sound good.
... Weeell, that might've been a horrifying mistake. Hello, Desperado here.
So how do I...
See I- whoops, I didn't mean to do that.
Whoo, okay. Hang on.
Alright, screw them! I'm going back to th-
I'm going back to this, because I don't know how to-
Woh. Why are you spouting out letters?
[Amused laugh] That's really cool!
That's a-That's a clever, unique- woah, hello.
Nope. No no no no no no.
What're you doing?
At least I have an actual gun now.
Woah, woah, woah, woah!
Poochie! Are you helping-
Oh, Poochie helps!
Ohh thank you, Poochie!
What did Poochie do? What is this?
What is that? Is that anything that I can use?
Heh. Nope.
Apparently not. I don't know what that do.
Noooo!
Wow, holy crap.
What the hell? That guy is BIG!
Hey buddy! Woah, no thanks you.
I'd rather not.
These guys aren't fucking around any- Whoa, god dammit!
Oh, it was a heart! Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
No, thank you.
Okay, so that was health,
that I could've used if I had lost any health prior to this.
At least it's not one hit kills, which is usually how it is in these... bullet hells.
At least it's a little bit of hope for me going forward.
Hello! Nope, not that way.
Heugh!
Anybody? Anybody wanna fight?
Nobody? Heh? Heh?
Heh? Heh?
Okay. Ok-
Oh, you! Where'd you come from?
Oh, okay.
Oh, NOW they're open. They weren't open before.
Alright, fine.
Hello! Whoa!
Hi there!
Dooon't do that!
I actually don't know if it's gonna be easier if- Wow.
I'm sorry!
I didn't mean to do that!
[giggle]
Alright.
I guess that's all in here.
There must be something on the other side, then.
[hup-ping sounds]
This is obviously not faster than anything, but it looks adorable when I do it.
Come on, poochie!
What are you? Should I kill you?
I'm just going to- Oh my god, it was just a horrible bird!
I just killed a bird!
Why did I d-
Oh. It's bullet-
Oh god. It's bullet-poopin' birds.
Okay. I don't feel as bad.
I WAS gonna feel bad, but now I feel totally fine.
Whoah! Hello.
Dadada. Okay!
It's like Dark Souls, except absolutely not like Dark Souls in any way.
In fact, I feel bad for making that comparison.
It's not-It's not even remotely like Dark Souls in any way.
It's literally nothing to do with anything that I was saying.
Anyway, I'm gonna shut up now
about the stupid thing that's not.
Okay, got that...
Hello!
I love that they come in with a bang.
Oh yeah. Sorry. [not sorry]
God dammit, you goopy bastard!
Get away from me.
Pooshie! Sic 'em!
Chica, get 'em!
[yell of puppy encouragement]
Yeah, I'm just gonna go...
I'm hoping that there's gonna be another boss here,
because I imagine that's what I'm aiming for here.
'Cause- Woah.
I mean I, I know that this is probably randomly-generated and-
and uh there's, there's a lot to be done in terms of replayability.
Kinda like a Binding of Isaac style randomly-generated dungeons where you find bonus items
and shit like that, and then eventually get upgrades for your gun and what not...
But I imagine...
I imagine that if that is the case-
Oooooh hello!
What are yoooooou!?
What is you?
What is going on? Is there something down here?
What does it say? What IS that? What's going on?
There's something over there! I don't know, maybe it's just not unlocked yet.
Hello!
Have you guys seen a boss around here anywhere?
No? Okay.
Tricked ya!
They seem to know where I am throughout the entire game,
so there's no point in hiding from anybody.
HEBEGH
HEBLETH
Hello!
Anybody wanna die?
Whoop, hello. Oh God!
Oh jeez!
That didn't look friendly at all! Ow!
I need to stop being so douche-y about this.
'Cuz I'm just-I'm just going in guns blazing,
excuse the pun, but I'm going in guns blazing.
Oh!
Ohhhhh.
So the bullets are MONEY!
Ohh, that makes more sense!
Okay, so THAT's what that was!
It was a secret passage, but it just wasn't activated yet
and that guy's the shopkeeper.
Okay, good! I'll be more mindful about collecting things, but I've just been kinda...
enjoying the moment of everything else.
Hello, buddy!
No.
No no no no nope! Whooh!
God, that is terrifying! You are big and slow but I don't like you.
Thank you.
Hello!
Nope! God, it's so sad when they die!
I never thought of bullets having any sort of emotion or anything,
so the fact they're, like this entire dungeon is populated by-
Oh, hello!
-is populated by these things is kinda weird.
'Ring of Mimic Friendship - Unlikely Allies'.
I don't know what that means, but I like it!
Does that mean they're gonna turn on my side every once in a while?
Because it's kinda lonely down in this dungeon.
Just fending for myself no matter what happens.
This gotta be where the boss is.
Oh! Yeah, it is! Okay.
BRING IT ON!
That's so cool!
But bring it on anyway!
Who- aaaaawww.
It's gonna be Heavy from Team Fortress 2!
[Not-Heavy squack]
Oh, it's a bird! Aw, I should have known!
That's a bird nest, that makes a lot more sense now.
Okay, I got it. Oh my god, that's so cool!
Oh god, that's SO COOL!
[Excited laughter]
Okay, anyway...
Ohhh man, 'Gatling Gull'?
That is- that is almost embarrassingly bad.
Wooow, hello!
Okay!
You have fun with that- ooh that doesn't seem good...
Okay, there's nothing. Nothing new here...
Woa hey! Woow... wow wow wow wow wow.
You're lucky I love bullet hells and I'm good at them, kind of!
Not really.
Oohkay! Whop!
Hup!
Oh, I can just hold- why was I- I was pressing it individually,
why did I need to-
WHOW!
[Intense Concentration]
Whoa- ah, goddammit! Got caught up on the table.
Hup!
At least I'll get some cover from this asshole...
Oh no! This is the one part where I get to wail on you over and over!
Can I- Oh, I got to re-press it to reload, that's what I gotta do.
[actually making okay progress for Markiplier standards]
Okay okay, almost gotcha.
Woop!
Hoop!
I probably shouldn't try to get so cl-
Heeeey! What're you doing there?
What do you think you're doing?
Hup!
Miss me!
Miss me! Whoo, didn't miss me there!
Hup!
Ah, jeez.
Ah jeez.
Oh gearsh.
Oh gosh!
Noo- Oh my god, I've only got one health left!
Come on, come on, come on. Oooh, don't fuck this up now!
[SQUISH of VICTORY]
YEEEEAH FUCK Y'ALL!
[Post-murder laugh]
I cared- [whoops]
I killed the rare and mysterious bird known as 'Gatling-
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
"Hegemony Credit? Accepted Galaxy-W"-
Ohhh, god.
Oh god!
Ohhh, no-hoho!
Why did you do that?
[Sad sounds]
[Dead bird to be forgotten in 3, 2, 1...]
Hey, cool!
'Prototype Railgun'.
[GASP]
SWEET!
[pew]
AW, IT'S SO COOL!
Aw, it's so cool!
It's so cool!!
Oh my god, that is the coolest.
That is the coolest!
That is the COOLEST!
Oh my god, that's so cool!
Okay. So anyway!
That's all the time I got for this episode, welcome to Enter The Gungeon.
This is RIDICULOUSLY cool and I can't wait to play more of this in the future.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you think of this game in the comments below.
And try for yourself! It's on Steam, I forget how much it is, but it's, uh-
I'll put a link in the description.
Thanks again! And as always,
I'll see YOU
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]